i don't think they're done number six
for the patriots and nobody believed
bill belichick said it himself from the
podium as they got the trophy no one but
they counted out from the start of the
scene what a what a croc of course
people believed in the patriots but you
know what if you only want to listen to
the doubters and you shut out the ones
who are praising you and believing in
you hey that can be an ingredient in
prompting your team to achieve more than
anyone would have imagined chris end of
the day 13 to 3 lowest scoring super
bowl ever
almost a shutout and the patriots get it
done defensively against the rams look i
said this in the radio side chris if you
tell sean mcvay last week hey you know
what the patriots only scored 13 points
in super bowl 53. sean mcveigh's taking
that and he's running with it and he is
he is assuming he's going to need to
measure his ring finger for a big giant
gaudy ram super bowl ring yeah well i
mean sean uh sean mcveigh got a little
piece of humble pie on super bowl sunday
there's no doubt about that the the the
patriots defense where we've talked
about it a lot that's secondary it's
special it was in the conversation or if
not the best secondary all in football
but uh again i mean it's the new england
patriots at the end of the day doing
what they had to do to win this
particular game not worried about tv
ratings or how everybody thought it was
going to look on you know oh flashy sexy
big plays lots of points
they realize bill belichick at some
point during his preparation mike that
okay our defense can stop this rams
offense and we can play conservative on
the offensive side of the ball with tom
brady in our running game and we can win
a low scoring game and that's what they
chose to do and that's why they're new
england they're not worried about
narratives or anything else it was just
what it took to win this football game
they weren't going to let aaron donald
and dominic and sue ruin the game i
think that's the game plan that we saw
yeah and and we saw the defense really
on both sides clamped down on the
offenses but you're right bill belichick
was happy to do it and happy to force
jared goff into three and out three and
out three and out they had 57 total
yards in the first half of the game and
the pace
it felt like the patriots
were letting them hang around right for
too long i mean if this was the plan i'd
like to think that the intent was to
score a few more points in the first
half they had the missed field goal they
had some opportunities they had a huge
time of possession advantage they had a
significant yardage differential
and and it just felt like it was getting
dangerous for the patriots in the second
half especially when the rams finally
snap out of it and brandon cooks is wide
open at the back of the end zone and
jared goff doesn't get him the ball in
time and it could have been seven to
three and that bubble pops all of a
sudden i just feel like the rams were
one play away from waking up they just
never could wake up chris they never
could make it happen they never could
come out of that funk and uh you know on
that last drive when they were down 10
and there was a greater sense of urgency
yeah they made it happen but it felt
like they were asleep the whole game and
nothing could get them out of it no you
know new england's size up front gave
the rams trouble in the running game you
know we just talked about the talent
they got in the secondary that slowed
down the pass game you know goff uh we
saw he's just not the type of
quarterback that can always make plays
with just his pure physical ability in
these type of moments gurley was a
non-factor none of the big-time
playmakers of the rams really had their
names called on a consistent basis right
and yes i mean to your point mike i
think you're 100 right i mean the pats
certainly wanted to score a few more
points and they were teetering on that
danger's ed but you edged but you talked
about it missed field goal we're driving
on the first drive when brady threw an
interception but at the end of the day i
do think they managed the game to be
somewhat ugly and they yeah maybe didn't
think it was going to be 13-3 but maybe
they thought they could win a game 20 to
10 20 to 13 that style of play but it's
just fascinating what new england has
done boston over la again just like the
world series yeah la i'm sorry it was a
great year but just like the world
series your team just isn't quite the
team that boston has uh the new england
patriots just find so many ways to beat
you and that's what they're amazing
bill's ability to collect a whole lot of
good and not have great in one area and
just makes them malleable to match up
against any team in football
first of all well done thank you
malleable good word thank you and you
set it properly thank you you get extra
points for that as well secondly you
don't have to apologize to la it's 4 a.m
out there they're not watching us right
now
the ratings
especially from that like are very low
right now but here's what i want to know
more about here's what fascinates me
we were led to believe that todd gurley
is fine he ain't fine we were led to
believe that he was going to be a huge
part of the game plan he wasn't a huge
part of the game plan and this idea that
while the opportunities weren't there
baloney because they weren't getting
blown out it's different if you're down
17 nothing and you have to abandon your
running game they just never got it
going and they never tried to trust
gurley and there was a long stretch in
the first half where he had one touch
and it was a back and forth close game
you got to reset every time that the
that the rams managed to get the
patriots off the field and get the ball
back it was a reset for that offense and
they never embraced gurley the way that
they led us to believe they were going
to i think he was a decoy i think
there's something wrong with him and i
think it's just a matter of time two to
four weeks from now we're gonna find out
that gurley had some sort of procedure
on that knee and he said it himself
after the game well we're gonna have our
physicals on our way out the door
something's not right with this guy and
it could be that he hid it from them
that he's kept it quiet and kept it to
himself and that's what's kept the team
from having to disclose it but that knee
i think isn't right that's the only
logical explanation at this point and
the only good news for gurley is he's
gotten himself paid before he started
this process of that career possibly
falling off due to whatever is going on
in that knee
most likely tracing to the acl that he
tore when he was in georgia well mike i
mean i agree with you there's something
there there's some issue i don't know
what it is but yeah i mean todd gurley
the way he's used the way he seems
content being used tells me that there's
some behind the door conversation about
i'm not a hundred percent or i'm not
quite myself i don't know what it is
exactly the season of you know wear and
tear and maybe they rode him too hard
you know through the first 11 weeks
where he kind of just died out at the
end but either way just disappointing
for all these guys i mean the rams are
such an exciting team all year long i'm
not only disappointed in girly and goff
and you know some of the other
playmakers even on the defensive side of
the ball but sean mcveigh too you know
that was a disappointing performance how
much last week did we talk about mike
right like self scout thyself i didn't
see a whole lot of new wrinkles from
that rams offense i could be wrong i'll
have more answers on the wednesday show
when i watch the film and really deep
like do a deep dive but i didn't see
anything just watching on tv that i said
oh wow that's a cute little wrinkle i
doubt you did either oh wow that's a
neat way to do it i just felt like it
was status quo and status quo doesn't
get it done against the patriots
no not when you have two weeks to get
yourself ready and your opponent has two
weeks to get ready to face you and i
wish i could remember who who found this
and who talked about this because i'd
like to give them proper credit but at
some point over the past few days i saw
something somewhere on tv
showing that the rams had gone back to
the well three different times in the
nfc championship game with with jared
goff rolling out to the right they did
it in overtime and he had two guys in
his face and he made a great kind of
close your eyes and hope for the best
throw on second and 13 to help push the
ball toward the winning field goal
margin but you can't pull that crap
against the patriots you can't use the
same play twice you can't you definitely
can't use the same play three times
it'll be interesting to see what you
find in the film but
may is it possible
is it possible
that kid genius yeah while still a kid
may not be the genius that that we've
all assumed that he is is it are we
allowed to even say that they're not
watching in l.a so maybe we can but but
is it possible chris well i wouldn't go
that far i'm not going to sit here and
say i mean i'm not gonna wipe away a
full really two years worth of evidence
to say that that offense has been hot
mcvay's done so many good things but uh
i do think that we've seen at least here
down the stretch you know he's had to
manage things a little differently too i
think i think that with the girly factor
i think we got to remember that and i
think the fact that jared goff really
since the bye week has not been the same
player that's been able to create some
plays he lost his mojo that mcveigh's
had to manage games differently on the
offensive side of the ball so i'm not
giving him an excuse because i do think
that you know hey i expect more to sean
mcvay down the stretch i didn't have
games on film where i said wow the rams
became a running team the last few weeks
of the season the playoffs they really
just said we're gonna run the ball and
we're gonna just have some timely
passing with jared goff i think all of
those things have led into it let alone
your theory on gurley which i gotta
think there's some issue there but more
than nothing more than anything mike
they ran into the team they're
kryptonite they really did every team's
got a kryptonite in football and the we
talked about it last week the patriots
were the size team the rams were the
speed team and the size team up front
they played that bear defense where they
covered the two guards in the center and
new england who's so much bigger than
people realize just said go ahead try to
run it we got three big dudes in here a
whole lot of man meat in there like 900
pounds a guy and dare run there if you
try and then they clog that up and then
of course we've talked about that
secondary to slow down woods and cooks
and everybody else and that's just bill
belichick uh back at the genius genius
level talk about super genius i'll call
him that all week not you
week 11 the rams scored 54 points 11
weeks later they scored three points and
and all those people that were clutching
pearls in the aftermath of 105 point
explosion by the rams and chiefs they
were probably asleep by halftime last
night so
congratulations you got what you wanted
you got a defensive struggle that no one
really wanted to watch why did you take
a break one more return
go ahead as i say do you think it was
the most boring super bowl in recent
history like for you was it what did you
think you were there
oh recent history absolutely now it's
still the super bowl and then the stakes
are as high as they can be and that that
creates some inherent excitement but it
felt like one of those crappy games from
the 70s when it was 24 to 3 and 23 to
seven and 16 to six and 14 to seven and
and uh you know we almost had the first
shutout in super bowl history and it
very well could have been it's the last
thing we would have expected in this
year of offensive firepower and
quarterbacks playing at a high level it
it makes it a a stunning outcome
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports